so when i was 18 i went to germany for  the summer and decided to convince my  mom that i got a tattoo even though i  didn't so an old nanny of mine posted  this picture on facebook and it was me  in front of the tattoo shop in the  comments we had a picture of the  so-called tattoo  and a story for why i got it clearly  this was made up and for real my mom  hates tattoos so this is what she said  seriously did you get a tattoo how mad  would you be you probably don't want to  know we aren't european and what they  think is okay we don't so that would be  the answer it's trashy oh  then this is awkward don't act like you  didn't already know this i hate tattoos  and so do you i hope you're smart enough  to put it in a place where no employer  coach boss or potential date will see it  and judge the whole thing was a joke but  i was curious can anyone else relate on  this app parents hate tattoos